hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
i see all kinds of interesting questions
here
uh
let's see a few saved up here there's
one from aaron
as wolfram language grows will the
number of lines of code ever shrink what
would cause such a trend
so first thing to say waltham language
is the big software system that i've
been building well
kind of directly for 35 years and
in some ways for 43 years or so
it's our computational language to kind
of represent everything in the world
computationally
and it's used by lots of people
uh
what is it ultimately well i haven't
counted recently but i think it's
probably about 50 million lines of code
that's the internal code that defines
this language it's the thing that
defines
all the things that compute you know the
distance to the moon or compute
something about uh the color
distribution in some image all those
kinds of things
maybe that estimate is actually too low
maybe it's closer to 100 i'm not i'm not
sure
but uh
what actually is the internal code that
implements all of those things when you
type something like edge detect
in
language
that
the actual code that runs is this big
chunk of code that tries to figure out
all the different methods it might use
to deal with all the pixels in your
image and do all those different kinds
of things
uh very often there are sort of meta
algorithms where you'll ask it to do one
particular thing like
do some machine learning operation it
has many different ways it might do that
and it has to select for your particular
problem which one to use so there's lots
of different pieces like that
okay
what is that code well
some of that code is both language code
so in other words what it's doing is
it's saying
there's a function
let's say it's a function that's nesting
other functions or something
you can write
that function in terms of other wolfram
language functions so in other words you
can write a new function in terms of
existing world language functions
and over the last probably 20 years
most of the new code that's been added
to the world language is written in the
language itself
some of it the very low level code is
written in the c language or actually an
extension of the c language which is a
language that gets really much closer to
low-level language that gets kind of
close to the underlying operation of the
of the hardware of the computer
now
uh c language is a compiled language so
from you write your code and then you
run the compiler program and it turns
your code into raw machine code that can
be explicitly run directly by the cpu of
your computer
in wolfram language the most direct way
that things work is if you've got that
thing that says you know do edge
detection or something edge detect it
will
uh it will that will be a piece of code
which will be then uh just run at that
time it will not be it will already have
been
turned into the form that needs to be to
run
it's not something where
if you if you build a piece of code in
waltham language uh the most
standard operation is that that piece of
code will be will be gone through at the
time when you ask it to run rather than
we initially turned into machine code as
a separate compilation step and only
later actually run on your computer
okay so
uh
what determines the length of the code
one has well
the the thing that has made the code of
autumn language as short and maybe 100
million lines doesn't seem short but as
comparatively short given the
functionality of the language as it is
is that the building blocks that one can
make use of in that code a very high
level building blocks
so
whereas in a low level language you
might say i want to move data around
from here to there i want to make this
loop that adds this
value to this and does that and then
does that and so on there's a lot of
code you have to write to specify what
you want to have happen because it's
very low level code in wolfram language
there's things where there's just
something that represents i don't know
edge detect an image take that take that
image and change the colors in it and so
on those are just single commands
in some lower level language those will
be ten hundred line hundreds of lines of
code or something that computes i don't
know the the uh uh the shortest tour
going around a bunch of points on the
surface of the earth um there's a lot of
different sort of moving parts that are
needed to make that work but in wolfram
language it's just one command
so
what happens is
the whole idea of organ language is to
make a language where it provides
building blocks that are as high level
as possible building blocks that sort of
do the operations that you might think
of doing computationally and do them in
a very in a way where what you have to
specify is as minimal as possible
so given those building blocks each
brick
kind of packs a lot of a lot of power
and so when as you build these programs
with these kind of
sort of mega bricks
that wolven language provides you're
building a program that can sort of
correspond to a very tall tower
so the more that the higher level the
code the more each individual function
in the code does each built-in function
of code does
the the more functionality you're going
to be able to get for a smaller amount
of code
and the lower level the language is the
the less functionality you're going to
get per line of code so what might be
one or two lines of language code might
be
3 000 lines of c code
or at least hundreds of lines of c code
and so the higher level language the
shorter the code
now
uh how does that work in terms of the
code of organ language well
the thing is what we always try to do in
building wealth and language is when we
see a piece of computational work that
is repeatedly done
and that we can sort of specify a name
for
that becomes a built-in part of language
so for example
it's a good example recently
oh
i don't know i can think of
i don't know subset replace maybe not
the most least obscure example
um
but
it's a thing that
uh you can write subset replace
a collection of perhaps i don't know
three lines of code or something
but it's something where you see that
that particular sort of idiom for code
repeatedly and so we sort of turn it
into a single word subset replace so
when you come back to use it again
now in a new version of ortho language
all you have to do is say subset
replaced you don't have to give those
three lines of code it's kind of like in
a human language uh before there's
really a word for something like a i
don't know a live stream for example
before there was a word for live stream
you might have have explained that of oh
i'm going to
connect to the the web and people are
going to we're going to
send this video and many people will
watch it and it's a whole multi-sentence
explanation and then eventually when
that's commonly enough used
in a human
in a human language um excuse me
sorry
when when some
kind of statement
is commonly enough used in human
language
then
oh boy
then you end up
you end up developing like a single word
that represents all those things the
single word live stream
that stands in for that whole sort of
block of
of words that you might have used before
and that's what we should try to do
in wolfen language as well is when we
see this kind of repeated block of
computational work we replace it by kind
of a single word that represents that
whole block
so
if we then come back through and we say
look at all this code we wrote before
now we have a a better way to specify
those same ideas using this kind of
shorter uh using this new building block
that we've made which makes everything
shorter
so the usual term in software
engineering would be something like
refactoring the code
it's sort of a new way to do the same
thing with code and it's something that
uh we do a certain amount of we come
back through and we change code that was
sort of written a long time ago in this
in this rather complicated way and now
we have some function that just does the
same thing but in a much more compact
way usually when we do that that single
function
is a little bit more powerful than the
block of code that you explicitly wrote
before it has because we've just got one
place to implement this you can
sort of put more effort into dealing
very efficiently with all the different
cases it's much better to have that
single encapsulated uh sort of
well-implemented function than to have
all that explicit code that you wrote
okay so that's one one trend another
trend is that we are steadily getting
rid of all c code that we had in the in
the code base of
language
and um
uh part of the way that we're doing that
is we are building a new generation of
compiler for our language
so we're able to go from those
specifications of language
down to in the end actual raw machine
code so we can take these very high
level representations of things and
compile that through some intermediate
language down to machine code and so
the the version so we're replacing c
code with essentially just pure standard
wolfram language code although in order
to make it as efficient as possible
we're giving hints in that wolf and
language code that tell the compiler uh
things about how it should compile that
code so that's another thing which over
time over the next few years will
probably make vast swaths of the source
code of wolfen language much shorter
so it's really that kind of refactoring
process of now we've got new building
blocks with which to implement what
we're doing that will make the code tend
to be shorter and and generally it's
better to have shorter code it's better
to have code that is in these made in
these modular pieces where there's one
piece here that is reused over and over
and over again and where that piece is
just implemented once rather than sort
of semi copies of that piece implemented
in many different places the reason
that's a good idea is because let's say
that you want to improve that piece of
code well you only have to improve it
once you don't have to go search for oh
did i do something like this in these
different places before and so on
now one thing that can happen to code
and a reason to kind of do that kind of
refactoring is it's sort of a strange
thing you might think
that
software code once it's written it's
there for all time
but it isn't really true in practice
code has this terrible habit of rotting
as people will say what does that mean
what that means is you have a piece of
code and it does a particular set of
things and then somebody notices oh what
about this weird case
maybe we should put in a little extra
piece of code to deal with if this
happens then do this special thing and
then maybe somebody else notices oh you
can make this more efficient by breaking
that into lots of different cases but
then there's one case that gets handled
differently and so on and so on and so
on and pretty soon over the course of
years as people make these little tweaks
to a piece of code the code gets more
and more and more complicated and it
gets more and more to the point where
nobody can really understand in detail
what it's doing
and and so that's the sentence in which
sort of code has this habit in practice
of sort of rotting um and that's the
thing where if you come through and you
say okay we're going to take the basic
functionality of this piece of code and
we're just going to re-implement it
using the sleekest best
new
capabilities and functions that we have
you'll usually come out ahead it'll
usually be a better thing to do you'll
remove sort of bugs that developed from
all of that tweaking that got done
you'll bake it using more maintainable
building blocks but you only have to
kind of service them in one place rather
than dealing with all those different
places and so on
so anyway that's a few thoughts on um on
on shrinking of code it's really a
feature of i would say high quality
software engineering that there is a
gradual rate of doing that kind of
refactoring of code on a time scale of 5
10 15 years whatever it is um that uh uh
that one
once it refreshes the code um so that uh
um
so that one kind of deals with this kind
of this this collection of tweaks that
build up sometimes in practice in the
computer industry there are things that
sort of force that refresh like there's
new kinds of computer hardware like
one's gone from 32-bit computers to
64-bit computers and some things have
changed actually in our code base that
affects almost nothing we have a from
the very beginning we had sort of set
the code up so that it basically just
has one file that specifies all those
kinds of things like is it a 32-bit
machine is it a 64-bit machine and
everything else kind of flows through
and computes what it should do based on
that
but
sometimes there are these drivers from
from the the way that the computer
industry evolves that sort of force of
re-looking at code sometimes for us it's
that in a particular area we realize
there are different things that can be
done we want to add a lot of
functionality in that area or sometimes
it's there are new algorithms that we've
developed or that other people have
developed that are relevant for that
area and need to be implemented
all right let's see
um
gosh
uh
all right a few questions here there's
one from frost here talking about
scientists trying to elucidate the
origins of life on earth the current
focus is exploring the rna world
uh
saying that a good 4.5 billion years ago
that seems a little long ago i would
have thought it was a little less time
than that
could there have been things like
dimension fluctuations back then how
different could the universe have been
back then
the universe is steadily expanding
um and
there are features of the universe that
certainly change over time for example
right now
the radiation that's left over from the
big bang at the beginning of the
universe
it has a temperature throughout the
universe of three degrees above absolute
zero um back
uh billion a couple of billion years ago
that temperature will have been much
somewhat higher like 10 degrees above
absolute zero what difference that will
made sort of here on earth i doubt it
made very much
um i think by the time the solar system
was formed uh sort of the universe would
have been locally at least not much
different from the way it is today
i mean in uh you know they're clearly
things that happen in our galaxy over a
time scale of billions of years
you know i don't think the the sun has
not gone around this around the galaxy
the gut the sun orbits the center of the
galaxy i think it's only gone around
maybe 50 times um since the sun was was
formed um and five billion years ago or
so
and um
which is about you know the universe is
maybe 14 billion years old so the sun
has been around maybe a third the time
the universe has
um but uh uh things will have happened
in our galaxy the black hole the center
of my galaxy is certainly getting bigger
if we lived near that
um then maybe there would have been a
more obvious change but as it is we live
out in one of the spiral arms in our
galaxy i'm pretty far away from those
kinds of things
so the question is in terms of our
theory of physics
there are things that happen in the very
early universe like the fact that we
have three dimensions of space that we
experience today
we think that in the very early universe
there were many more dimensions of space
and gradually sort of things cooled down
so that we have the number of dimensions
of space that we have today and we
expect that in the sufficiently early
universe there will have been kind of
dimension fluctuations instead of us
having three dimensions of space we'd
have like 3.01 dimensions of space and
so on um those dimension fluctuations i
would suspect don't know but i would
suspect that they're pretty much gone
by the time uh by the time the sun is
formed and so on
perhaps not
um it uh and perhaps
there
uh the thing to understand is that
there's plenty in our universe that's
left over
from that long ago for example there are
photons particles of light that have
been traveling through the universe
ever since well basically for 14 billion
years ever since the beginning of the
universe they've just been traveling
traveling traveling they didn't hit
anything finally we might detect them
and it's like after 14 billion years
flying through the universe splat the
photon hits you know our eye
or a detector that we have in space or
something like this
so
um but there are plenty of things that
get left over from the early universe
whether it's photons neutrinos uh there
might be some gravitational waves things
like that
that uh so
there are the kind of
uh things like atoms and so on
uh tend to be a much more recent lineage
that we see in in the universe today
uh actually that maybe that's not
correct the out in interstellar space
and intergalactic space there are
certainly hydrogen atoms that really
haven't nothing much has happened to
that hydrogen atom for most of the
history of the universe
um it's uh if you're in the in the
middle of a galaxy then all sorts of
things can happen to those hydrogen
atoms they can be in stars and they can
be as
sort of uh have uh
fusion in between other hydrogen atoms
and stars all those kinds of things
but so i i don't think that those purely
sort of physics and cosmology effects
are probably very important
for the things that happened in the
chemistry of the early earth that led to
the formation of life on earth
there are things people wonder about
like for example one feature of life on
earth
is there are some molecules
where you could have kind of a molecule
that has kind of a a right hand rule for
how a certain arrangement of atoms is
relative to other atoms or a rule it's
kind of the atoms can be arranged both
ways round and there's sort of a a
chirality a handedness to the molecule
sugar is an example of such a molecule
and in a sense the sugar that we
normally encounter in biology is
right-handed sugar the particular atoms
are arranged in the way that sort of
corresponds to something like sort of a
one thing sticking out that's like a
thumb and the other atoms arranged like
like the fingers on ones on one's hand
one one curls it up
um
the
when you just start making sugar from
its ultimate ingredients in a lab you'll
get equal amounts of left-handed and
right-handed sugar but in life on earth
it's all right-handed sugar and so one
of the questions which is something that
people look to very early earth
to to answer is why did lighted life end
up getting
you know all this all things that were
sort of one chirality one-handedness all
its molecules sort of be the
right-handed version of the left-hand
version and there are some theories that
that has to do with some details of the
way that cosmic rays uh particles
protons particularly coming from the sun
operate
and the kind of thing that happens in um
in in radioactive decay where it turns
out that the this handedness things are
not equally handed in radioactive decay
the main reason for that is that
radioactive decay so-called beta decay
that involves a essentially neutrons and
a neutron in the nucleus of an atom kind
of decaying into a proton an electron
and an anti-neutrino
so it turns out
that neutrinos are basically always
left-handed anti-neutrinos are always
right-handed that's a it's something
where there isn't sort of
equal-handedness of neutrinos that are
produced they're always left-handed ones
that are produced essentially
and that causes the electrons that are
produced in beta decay to have a another
kind of handedness and when those things
interact with chemicals
and in chemical reactions there will be
a slight tendency for the you know the
right-handed sugars to win out over the
left-handed sugars and over the course
of time and as biological evolution
takes root eventually the righties uh
get rid of the lefties so to speak as a
as a left-handed person myself about ten
percent of our humans are like that um i
i hate the idea of kind of the um uh the
right-handed everything molecules uh
sort of taking over the earth but that's
how it goes
um but anyway i think those are some
kinds of places where sort of raw
physics
interacts with the kind of the
biochemistry of the formation of life on
earth
in general the process of of how things
were formed in early life on earth
um there's a lot that's not known about
that yet but one of the things that
seems to be the case is that what's kind
of important is these chains of chemical
reactions that are kind of cycles of
chemical reactions where and that's sort
of a place in which
some kind of memory is retained because
it's kind of like uh molecule a turns
into b turns into c turns of d turns
back and a again
and that kind of the existence of that
kind of loop is some form of of kind of
simple chemical memory and that seems to
be an important thing in kind of some
features of the way that uh what turns
into life as we know it now with its
very long-term memory that's stored in
dna and in genomics and so on the way
that that arises and there's sort of
many steps from uh those kind of um uh
sort of loop reactions so to speak to uh
to the place where we actually get
things like dna and we get these sort of
permanent storage and molecules and and
perhaps there were surfaces like um uh
solid surfaces like clay for example
which could have been sort of imprinted
by these various kinds of chemical
reactions and been another kind of way
to store the memory of things and and
in life because because one of the
characteristics of life
is that it sort of progressively builds
in a sense that you have uh you know you
have some kind of chemical reactions and
then kind of take those for granted and
then you add more and so on it doesn't
always i've talked about this in other
cases it doesn't always get really more
complicated it's a little bit like the
code i was talking about earlier i mean
life biology does refactor things from
time to time as things get super
elaborate
uh eventually it'll turn out well that
incredibly elaborate you know
weird sort of horn shaped thing that's
on the on the heads of these kinds of
organisms ah that just wasn't that
important and why spend all your effort
doing that and oh every so often it gets
tangled up in in in a plant somewhere
and that's a bad idea and so that thing
stops being selected for by biological
evolution and disappears and you get
sort of the refactored organism where
that's simpler
and so that that happens in biology the
code gets simpler so to speak uh maybe
not the actual dna although that does
also get simpler
in different organisms we're certainly
not the organisms that have the longest
dna sequences of all organisms
um and uh
so so so that kind of thing happens
there
but um
yeah i don't think i don't think
that these kind of effects that come
from physics and cosmology are likely to
have had a big effect
on
uh on the um uh on directly on the
formation of life on earth i mean people
talk about you know for example the form
of our solar system which still looks a
little bit unusual relative to the
typical exoplanet systems that have been
seen but that may just be a phenomenon
of the only exoplanet systems we see the
ones that have a particular kind of
configuration of planets because those
are the things that we are able to
detect with our technology today
but um it could be the case that some
some kind of external sort of
astronomical phenomena have been
important in determining the way that
our solar system is
is arranged i mean for example it could
even be the case as the sun has gone
around orbiting the galaxy 50 times it
kind of as it does those orbits it goes
through these different regions of the
galaxy and maybe every so often it goes
close to other stars and maybe when it
gets very close to another star we're
not very close right now four light
years is the distance to alpha centauri
the nearest star uh other than the sun
but i don't know how long it will be but
but in some number of uh
hundreds of millions of years uh we'll
no doubt go close to some other stars
and uh you know if you look up the kind
of the the astronomy textbook
of uh 50 million years from now or 50
million years in the past it won't say
alpha centauri was the closest star to
the sun
um and there will be times in which
there are stars that get pretty close to
our solar system and when that happens
the gravity of those stars may perturb
the planets that are in our solar system
and that might have been an important
effect in determining the final
configuration of planets and that final
configuration of planets is important in
the fact that oh the temperature of the
surface of the earth is roughly this
because it's roughly this distance from
the sun
and it's maintained in a stable orbit by
the fact that oh there's this very big
planet jupiter here and so on and so on
it's a it's a whole collection of
different kinds of things and perhaps
even the fact that there were asteroid
impacts on the earth
well you have to have an asteroid belt
to have asteroid impacts and the fact
that there's an asteroid belt in our
solar system we don't know for exoplanet
systems yet um
solar systems around other stars we
don't know that yet for them um
that the fact that there is an asteroid
belt here might be for some detailed
reason of some planet got you know uh
collided with another planet or or
didn't form into a planet because of the
effect of the gravity of some other star
as the sun orbited the the inside the
galaxy so there are complicated kinds of
things like that
um
let's see there are questions here
so many different questions another one
from aaron why small children able to
spin around so quickly without getting
dizzy while adults become nauseous
okay it all has to do with our inner
ears
um and these things called ooh let's
spell o-o-l-i-t-h
um
so
it's how do we know which way is up
well
it's really important that there's
gravity that defines which way is down
so to speak and none of the things i'm
talking about work if you're weightless
in space if you're in zero gravity just
sort of floating without a definite pull
direction to gravity but when there is a
definite pull direction to gravity
the the big the question for your brain
our brains
is uh which way is up
and so on
and
the way we determine that it's kind of
clever
inside our ears there are these things
called semicircular canals there are
basically these little loops
that are made from bone
um and they are in in three different
directions they're kind of in the x y z
coordinate directions three loops
and inside those loops are these little
tiny things called ubuliths
which are little essential stones
and when
we are
and those as we turn our head for
example
those stones will kind of
move around they'll slide around inside
those semicircular canals to the place
where they are at the lowest point for
example
uh if we're accelerating if we are kind
of being spin around uh i should say
that that under when you're not when
you're standing still
it's just determined by the force of
gravity and the our lifts will kind of
adopt the lowest point um in
in those semicircular canals
if you spin around
it's like the centrifugal force okay so
you spin around you take some something
and you spin it around it's on a string
let's say it tries to pull outwards
why is it trying to pull outwards well
if you left it to its own devices
it would like to just go in a straight
line kind of a basic law of motion
newton's second law newton's first law
actually is um if uh
that
things that are just in motion in a
certain direction will just keep going
in that direction and will not deviate
from that direction
uh when there's no gravity when there's
no forces acting on things that's what
happens then just keep going in a
straight line
so if you're whirling that thing around
your head
you have to stop it doing what it
otherwise wants to do it wants to just
keep going in a straight line but in
order to stop it doing that you have to
continually exert this force that is
pulling it in to prevent it from going
in a straight line
and
what you have to when
if it was going in a straight line
there'd be no acceleration to its motion
it would just be going at a certain
fixed speed fixed velocity and you
wouldn't but acceleration is the change
of velocity the change of speed or the
change of direction of motion um and so
what you're doing when you keep the
thing going round in a circle
is you are uh you keep on changing the
direction of motion so you are keeping
on accelerating things
when you accelerate things there is this
force that tends to make things that
because things want to sort of keep
going in a straight line you have to
exert a force to prevent them doing that
end result kind of obvious in its own
right those little lifts in your inner
ears if you spin around
they'll sort of go to the outer part of
those the the sort of the semicircular
canal um just like that thing that you
spin around your head on a string would
go as far away as it can sort of in that
circle as it's spinning around
so
what will tend to happen is as you
accelerate as you spin around for
example the um those little little
little tiny rock-like things in your
inner ears will try and will try and get
to the place where they are sort of
maximally spun out so to speak
okay that's all fine
it's pretty gooey inside one's inner ear
and
the um uh
i think as one gets older it gets gooier
and so
this like this this sort of the the easy
sliding of these oolets through the
inner ear tends to be something that
gets more difficult or can get more
difficult as one gets older
and
well this question of
and so this issue of um
actually it's not quite explaining the
dizziness question but let me let me
come to that in a second
so one of the things that can happen you
can get an infection
of your the labyrinth as it's called in
your inner ear
and uh when that happens you can get
into a situation where
you um
uh
uh where these oolitts get stuck because
there's infection in there and they just
they can't um there there's something
there's i don't know what it is
bacteria maybe i'm not i'm not quite
sure actually that that is inside that
that um
um
that semi-circular canal anyway it gets
gummed up in some way
there is this very weird maneuver
that um has a name which i now forget
um
that one can use if the ooh lifts
someone's ears gets stuck in a certain
position it's a it's a weird kind of
exercise that involves kind of turning
spinning oneself around and turning
around this way and holding one's head
that way and turning one's head this way
and essentially it's like it's like one
of those puzzles where you're trying to
get the piece out of the puzzle um
you're trying to get the ulrich out of
where it's been wedged in your inner ear
and it's really quite bizarre effect i i
happened to me once i got some kind of
weird thing where i was getting some
weird sort of dizziness and i try this
this um this strange marooba i i'm very
bad at kind of imitating instructions
but if you find a video on the web or
something of how to do it um you can you
can learn that you do it once
and oh my gosh
you're not dizzy anymore it's it's
really a weird thing
um okay why do people get dizzy what's
going on there
the um
i think the main thing that's happening
is
that
you have
a mismatch between
what your eyes see about how you're
moving your head and what you sense in
terms of the motion of your head and i
think what happens is
that the um
uh that kids where these lifts are
running all nice and
and smoothly and things as they turn
their head
they the things that
their sensation
of where their head is oriented agrees
with what their eyes are telling them
about where their head is oriented so
all's good
but when that gets out of whack
when there's a there's a delay for
example between
how what the the sensation of the
orientation of your head is relative to
what your eyes
are showing it's kind of running your
brain really fast trying to figure out
what earth is going on and that
that shows up in being dizzy and i think
sometimes when you're dizzy you spun
around it's kind of like you feel like
you're keeping on spinning and that's an
effect having to do with the your your
inner ear and those ooh lifts in your
ear somehow continuing to move um and
they hadn't they haven't finished their
motion and gotten to where they were
going to they're sort of still moving um
even after you're not moving anymore
because they just have some viscosity to
to motion
um i think at least now one of the
places where this shows up again is with
virtual reality headsets
and i have to say i actually have not
won one in a little while even though
even though the metaverse is big i kind
of got um got put off uh so to speak
because i've used these things many
times and
one of the things that happens is i get
a kind of motion sickness when i use
them
and and the real thing that is the
difficulty for virtual reality
systems is
what's happening is there's a
it's trying to show you you know you
have a head mounted display and it's
trying to show you as you turn your head
you start to see a different view
and that has to be done as a piece of of
of sort of computation
that you know you turn your head
the the the headset senses the
orientation of your head it has these
things called mems
um which are kind of semiconductor
devices that sense acceleration and from
that sense orientation
and so there the the the headset is
sensing the direction that your head is
in but then it has to sort of repaint
the screen
to show you what that scene was you know
you're looking straight ahead at that uh
dinosaur or something and you look to
the side and there's another dinosaur
about to attack you there or whatever it
is but it has to show you that part of
the visual scene
that would correspond to what you would
see if you turned your head in that way
and the question is does it how quickly
does it do that or does it have a delay
in doing that and even the slightest
delay there causes all kinds of problems
uh in our brains and visual perception
and so on and for me personally uh at
least the up until the the six months
ago
version of vr headsets i can only be in
them for for five or ten minutes because
beyond that i get terrible motion
sickness from some kind of thing that my
brain is doing or not doing or whatever
about the timing of uh i think about the
timing of of how the actual image lines
up with the uh with the with the
orientation of my head and and oh and
yeah the other the other factor here is
that i can feel in my
uh
uh inner ear in this
semicircular canals and ooh lifts and so
on i can feel what the orientation of my
head is and if things don't agree if
what i see in the virtual reality
headset doesn't agree with what should
be the case from the orientation that i
can feel from my head
i get very confused and i get very
motion sick
so let's see
uh
it's a question from d0 here are there
parts of our body that we evolved away
do we still need the appendix
you know
there's a terrible tendency
in many areas of science and in medicine
to say
oh gosh
we don't know what that does so we don't
need it um
this is
unfortunately
it's very hard to know for sure what
something does
um i mean sometimes it's obvious
but sometimes it's not i mean there are
even parts of the brain where people
even 50 years ago or so were like that
doesn't do anything useful you can just
remove that part and nothing bad will
happen turns out that wasn't true it
wasn't obvious that nothing bad happened
because it wasn't a part of your brain
that actually made you be able to move
your hand or something like this but it
was a part of your brain that was
important in sort of uh aspects of
of personality that were a little bit
harder to measure
so this this idea of uh you know it's
not something you need one can take it
out
um is uh uh is i think fraught with
difficulty as far as the appendix is
concerned it's this kind of strange
knob on on the side of the intestines um
and it's a place where
you know one can be unlucky and get
something stuck in it and then it can
get infected and one can have
appendicitis and that's bad
um
and
the um uh but you know why is it quotes
why is it there is it there just because
our intestines evolved from the
intestines of of you know of lower
mammals and things like this and it kind
of never got taken out
not clear it's not clear there might be
things for for example there's
increasing evidence
that the flora the the the the kind of
bacteria that live in our gut are
important for
providing all sorts of things that
relate to our overall health
for sort of tuning up our immune system
for
for interacting with the rest of our
bodies in a variety of ways and it could
be the case that
that's you know that something like the
appendix it's there because oh you
actually want some kind of pieces of
benign bacteria to hang out there and
you know sun themselves for a while
rather than getting flushed through the
whole intestinal system or something
like that and i'm just making up that
explanation um but uh
in other words it's it's not obvious you
know when you see some something like
that and gradually you learn that the
microbiome of bacteria that live in our
gut are much more important than people
assumed in the past and you know we have
our bodies are this pretty complicated
system of many interdependent parts
uh i think there are sort of two forces
that go on one is the interdependent
parts really depend on each other the
other is
in a sense many of those parts have a
certain universality to them so if you
take one part away other parts will be
able to compensate and
sort of fill in the function that you
need from that part
and doesn't always happen that way but
it's something where those are sort of
two counter balancing forces that
everything is interdependent yet
any one thing can be sort of filled in
from other things in many cases
so i think in terms of the what evolved
away i mean you know famous thing is we
don't have tails anymore we have kind of
a bone at the the base of our spine
that's kind of like where the tail might
have attached but there ain't no tail
there um anymore and um you know that
that's an example now presumably if you
know our distant ancestors were hung out
in trees a lot it's good to have a tail
if you're swinging from tree branch to
tree branch tails are really an
important thing in arranging for you to
keep balance and so on um but uh in us
you know us sort of boring bipeds that
um don't spend a lot of time swinging
from from tree branch to tree branch at
least most of us don't um the tail is is
something that uh wasn't so important
and i don't know why
uh you know generally evolution does
tend to simplify things uh if the tail
is really unnecessary the tail might
cause trouble it might get you know it
might get infected it might get jammed
somewhere it might be something that
some predator can catch hold of or
whatever um it might be inconvenient for
one reason or another to have a tail and
so gradually if you really don't need
the tail the the the fitter organisms
will not have the tail and the tail will
gradually disappear in the population
let's see
um
oh my
questions here that get quite
philosophical um
let's see
uh
it's a question from icy here
is science getting harder
are ideas getting harder to find
i don't think so
i think
the doing of science as a profession
is in some ways easier and in some ways
harder
but the process of solving problems in
science
i
would say
it's definitely not getting harder and
in some ways it's getting easier
why do i say that so you might say
people have been doing science for
hundreds of years maybe even thousands
of years haven't all the easy questions
been answered
well what happens is
once
one set of questions get answered they
become the building blocks for sort of
building out something where you can now
answer new questions
the things that were
sort of the difficult questions of long
ago become the things we take for
granted today and the things that we are
kind of standing on to reach new
questions today
and so i think
the um if anything the kind of the the
waterfront of i don't know i'm wondering
is it the case that there's a sort of a
broader range of areas that have now
been opened up to the point where we can
ask questions about them than they were
in the past i'm not sure um i think it's
probably stayed almost the same um but i
think what happens is that in any given
area of science
there will be a set of foundational
questions there'll be work done on those
maybe they'll be answered maybe they
won't be answered maybe some of them
will be answered there'll be a
development of a building of that sort
of tower of results in that particular
area of science and it gradually builds
and you kind of are uh the new science
that you're going to do is going to be
at the top of that tower
okay so
uh
and
but
to us
in a sense
education
is about kind of getting us to the point
where we know about what's in the tower
that's already been built research is
about what's getting us to the next
level of the tower so to speak
and
gradually the education gets easier to
do
because
the well for a couple reasons
one
the concepts that get developed
when a concept is first developed it's
often developed in a rather complicated
way because people didn't understand
what was important about it it's
strangely similar to that code
refactoring and that biological
simplification i was just mentioning
it's sort of you can get an idea or
concept and it just manages to reach
where where you're talking about things
but it's really kind of difficult to
explain and you know there's no good
description there's no good word for
this and we've got six levels of
definitions for that and so on and so on
and so on and gradually over the course
of time people understand what's
important and the whole thing gets
simpler and simpler to the point where
it's much more direct and easy to
explain
um so that that's one force that makes
things kind of get
uh
uh get get sort of easier to explain
another thing that can happen is you can
end up with a situation where at first
you say
oh we've got um
uh all these different creatures on the
earth and they all have different kinds
of uh
um you know
one has a has a thing that sticks out
that looks like this another thing has a
sticks out that looks like that another
one like this and so and then we
realized actually those are all kind of
the same type of thing let's say they're
all birds and they've all got wings and
beaks and things like this
and we don't have to sort of start
talking about oh it's this beaky thing
and it's got um it's got this feature in
that feature in the other it's just it's
a beak and that becomes sort of this
abstract generalization that we can just
say once rather than having to say
there's this preacher that has this
there's that creature that has this and
so on and so it is with many areas of
science
that um
and other things that we end up having
these sort of generalizations these
abstractions that we can kind of say
once once we understand that
generalization we can kind of say it
once and communicate it educationally
just once rather than having to go in
and say there's this case and there's
this case and there's a space in this
case all these things to remember
another dynamic that makes sort of
education easier
is that the things that become part of
everyday life get broader
there are things i don't know
uh for instance some the way hyperlinks
work on the web
everybody's pretty way familiar with the
fact you click something it's a link to
something else
well the notion of graphs and networks
of there are things and they're linked
to other things and there's this whole
network of links
that's something which
before there were things like hyperlinks
might be a little bit hard to explain
now that people are used to this idea of
links to links to links and so on it's
it's a lot easier you have a basis for
explaining that idea um so it becomes
easier it becomes something that's part
of sort of everyday life and so it
becomes something you can kind of take
as the base level and not have to go
into a long explanation of it
so so that sort of helps to make things
easier to explain and all of this helps
to
get it to the place where sort of
through education one has built this
kind of platform of where science has
reached so far
and then the question is from that
platform how far is it to the next
low-hanging fruit so to speak i mean
back when there was always no nothing
known in science there was a certain
there were a certain number of obvious
things that one could sort of reach in
some metaphorical sense and get
but gradually as science builds up and
we know more and more we're building
this sort of taller and taller platform
this torrent or tower
from the top of that tower there's now
new low-hanging fruits to get
now i have to say one of the things
that's been a feature of at least my
efforts in science
is that it's often the case that even
when you're you know there's a field
that has you know has built a pretty big
tower there are still foundational
questions that haven't been answered
they're sort of the most obvious and
some of the questions uh people you guys
ask here are sort of the obvious
questions in some sense uh they're good
questions often um about some particular
area of science
um and sometimes it's like you might ask
that if somebody knows that science well
and they would say if they if they if
they really know it well enough they'll
say look that answer is just not known
but other people
who have been working in that science
for a long time even will have never
thought about that foundational question
because it's something that got sort of
forgotten in the development of that
science and they'll usually as a
practical matter they'll say oh of
course somebody has answered that
say who's answered it where's it been
answered i said well well somebody's
answered it i'm sure somebody's answered
it you dig a little further and
eventually they realize
that's really odd you know although
that's a foundational and obvious
question nobody ever answered it
and
so what can often happen in the sort of
story of some of the things i've done in
science
is that
as you've built some other tower some
other collection of tools
for example particularly computational
tools
you can say oh there's this foundation
over here there's never answered let's
go in with our new tools and let's see
what we can do
and it often is the case that it's
actually rather easy to answer that kind
of foundational question which 50 or 100
years ago when it was first formulated
those tools didn't exist and that
question was very hard to answer and
people gradually sort of ignored the
question
and just went on and looked at the
things that they could answer so that
that's a um
that's a a way in which there can be
sort of hidden
uh soft target easy science so to speak
that can nevertheless be very important
i would say that in terms of the
institutional structure of science
it's gotten easier in the sense that
it's much easier to get educated about
science than many more venues to get
educated about science even
these uh little live streams that i do
are an example of a kind of a a way i
hope to get a bit educated about science
that sort of didn't exist in the past
but
then when it's a question of of of the
doing of science
as a if you're a professional scientist
um there's a certain amount of of
overhead of sort of dealing with this
large institutional structure of kind of
all the sort of bureaucracy of the way
that science operates and the way that
people write academic papers and they
they have sort of you know are you going
to publish my paper or not or how does
this work and you know does this paper
have the right
citations to this and that and there's
kind of a whole kind of bureaucratic
structure that you have to kind of work
through in order to do science as a
professional scientist today
and that has almost nothing to do with
the actual difficulty or not of solving
the actual scientific problems it just
has to do with the fact that there's a
there's millions of scientists literally
and um uh there's kind of this this kind
of a it's a it's a it's a complicated
kind of uh human bureaucratic structure
that maintains science and so that can
cause things to be more difficult
um
zayden comments that uh the more you
learn the more we've learned that
there's a lot more to learn
yes and no
you know one of the things that happens
is there'll be a field of science
that
defines itself in a certain way
and it has certain methods
and by golly with those methods it can
hollow itself out it can get everything
that we've got with those methods if
that doesn't often doesn't even take
very long it often takes decades two
decades something like that and some
area once some method has developed it's
like we can solve everything that can be
solved using that method and sometimes
people say the definition of that area
of science is what can be solved with
that method and so then once that method
has kind of scooped out everything
that's there you'd say oh there's
nothing more to know
now
what is being ignored in that is well
that was what you got with a particular
method
even that same set of scientific
questions if approached with another
method you open up this whole new giant
new you know uh uh run of stuff to do
so it's sometimes as the case i mean
throughout history people have been
uh you know there are all these
quotations
and i kind of am amused because because
i i hear these things for real and
people who have always laughed at them
in the past i mean like in in 1900 for
example i think there was a famous quote
from the chap who ran the patent office
in the in the us
that said you know everything useful
that's been that could be invented has
now been invented
um there similarly there were similar
comments around that time everything
interesting in science and physics has
already been discovered well that was
obviously absurd because in the light of
history the early 1900s was a period of
great
uh energy and expansion for example in
physics relativity quantum mechanics all
these kinds of things suddenly came on
the scene and they suddenly opened up
all these different areas how do people
end up
saying uh sort of that there's nothing
happening in fact a friend of mine who's
a well-known venture capitalist is is
fond of of of of saying that you know
look
uh you know innovation has slowed down
there's no innovation happening anymore
but i think what tends to happen is that
each of those people are looking at
innovation in a particular area
so it might be you know
there are no new
uh sort of social media startups that
are being created that are that are
particularly notable they all seem to be
doing the same thing there are no new
you know uh e-commerce startups or
something there are no new startup
companies in a particular model of what
a startup company is that uh well there
are new ones but they're not they don't
have sort of fundamental innovations in
them
but so what tends to happen is people
get confused because they'll look at a
particular area and they'll say
this area is getting hollowed out
there's nothing much more to do in this
area with the methods that we're doing
with the kind of thing you can do with
the silicon valley startup of this kind
and that kind you know kind of all the
things that were low-hanging fruit easy
pickings
in that area have been picked
and so then it's then it looks like oh
if that's what you're focusing on
there's nothing more to do
but the point is that
the the structure of kind of knowledge
tends to be that there's always
something else out there off in the in
the uh sort of uh out in a different
place
that uh where there is great innovation
to be done and what what sometimes
happens is there'll be innovation in
some area the area will get well worked
out and there will stop being so much
innovation
and it's like okay that's all done we
don't have to do anything more there
then there'll be some other area that's
sort of some distance away
it will have lots of innovation it will
build a taller toilet or a tower and
eventually that tower will come to to
affect that first area you were talking
about there's this kind of disruption
that can happen not from within
usually not from within that area that
area has just been the particular
methods that have been used that's been
worked through and everything that can
be done there's more or less been done
but when this other area with its other
methods comes online it can then go sort
of attack that first area and often make
kind of disruptive progress in that area
and this is something we see in
industries and and sciences and so on
it's it's one of the reasons uh when it
comes to education and so on it's one of
the reasons why the more you know the
better off you are because if you just
know that particular area that
particular methodology it's like okay
but that's all been worked out
and the real progress is going to come
from somewhere else and so you have to
kind of know
what you know has to span these
different areas for it to be possible
for you to make progress because if
you're just focused on that one first
area you're never going to make very
much progress
another thing that tends to happen is
people sometimes say
oh you know you want to do this area you
should just study this thing just study
that one tower and then and you'll get
you know the more you study that one
tower the taller you'll get you know the
further you'll get up that one tower
and that is is okay
if you just want to lay one brick on the
top of that tower if you really want to
reach significantly further you're
almost certainly going to have to get
something from another tower
um and i think that um
and what you see
often is
even the place where there is the most
innovation is sort of between the towers
there'll be two areas and they're both
pretty well developed but there's some
interface between those areas some
interdisciplinary area where which is
something where where those two things
never collided before so to speak but
now they are colliding now these two
fields have relevance to each other and
that's where the innovation is going to
happen that's where the the energetic
innovation is possible because it's
essentially a newly exposed kind of
methodology that one didn't have access
to before
and so i i think that's some uh that's
sort of a common dynamic is is that
there's this tower gets developed to a
certain point then there'll be some
other target that's developed then this
is kind of this empty space between them
and then you know that sort of things
start happening there and then another
tower gets built there and so on and
that's you know at least a
metaphorical picture of kind of the way
that progress happens
and you know i'm i'm fond of remarking
that in different fields of science
uh for example when they're well
developed enough that there's a named
university department there's a
collection of prizes named after that
kind of science
by the time one is at that stage the
high innovation period of that science
is over
or at least if it isn't over it's going
to be another 100 years before kind of
the things that were foundational before
um and were never solved in the
foundations get to be accessible from
tools from elsewhere
so so that's kind of a a um sort of a
picture of um
uh
of things oh and uh paul is commenting i
think in in relation to my comments
about how there's nothing more that to
be invented uh that it's ironic that
albert einstein started his revolution
in physics while working in a patent
office i i you know it is important to
to fill in a little bit more of that
history because it's you know often
scientific history is very cartoonized
and uh
you know it's like uh you know poor
einstein toiling away in the patent
office
and you know didn't really know much et
cetera et cetera et cetera and suddenly
inverts relativity figures out the
photoelectric effect you know invents
photons all those kinds of things
um and brownian motion and all that all
in 1905. you know how could this be
well let's be realistic you know albert
einstein had gone and gotten a phd in
physics
at
if not the top one of the top couple of
universities in the world at the time
uh it wasn't a particularly interesting
phd thesis but he had gotten sort of the
the highest level of physics education
that existed
what did he do
he did something that uh sort of i would
say perhaps entrepreneurial people might
do in today's world he went to the then
analog of silicon valley um which was
the patent office in in
bern
um where because at the time and and
perhaps it's ironic that yes it was a
time which the u.s examiner patents had
said there's nothing new to be
discovered but there were a lot of
patents being produced about things like
refrigerators and and all kinds of
things like that probably bicycles
things of that kind that were very hot
at the time
um ironic for refrigerators i suppose uh
but in any case so
this idea that um it's kind of like
uh the the you know the from nowhere
comes these theories of physics not to
not to
reduce
the um uh the importance i think i think
the thing about what einstein did and
this is more historical point
the thing that is interesting
it relates to this whole thing about
towers
of of science and so on in physics
there was a big tower that had been
built around differential equations and
mathematical physics and
and this and that and a big technical
tower that was pretty complicated
and then there were these effects
that
in the end would need relativity
and what einstein did in his original
paper on relativity
is he he just thought about conceptual
experiments you know what if you were
taking a mirror and you were bouncing
light off it and the mirror was going at
half the speed of light what would
happen these kinds of things
it's in a sense like a philosophy paper
it reads a little bit like the papers
that people or the things that people
wrote in ancient greek times where they
were trying to sort of reason their way
through the way the world works
it wasn't something built on the great
big tower
that
had been assembled in the physics of its
time it was something that came in using
a different methodology
and making use of certain experimental
results which were new
which had been which had come into
existence because of technology
innovations um those that was the reason
that it was possible to make sort of a
big jump forward was that not because it
was buildings brick by brick on this on
this existing tower but rather it was
coming in and making a foundational
having a foundational realization that
came from outside of that kind of tower
now you know in our own efforts with our
uh model of fundamental physics in the
last few years
which i i must say i view as being the
next big step
after what happened roughly 100 years
ago with the creation of relativity and
quantum mechanics and so on um i think
that's a case where there's been a lot
of technology built in physics a lot of
wonderful things done in it but in
fundamental physics there's sort of a a
paradigmatic a fundamentally different
set of ideas that are needed to make
progress now
and those are i think we've been lucky
enough to to find those ideas but where
did they come from you know they did not
come out of the main line of development
of physics as it's been done for the
last hundred years no they came from
ideas about computation
that came from sort of from the side
now you know i myself have been sort of
lucky enough to
have done physics and computation and so
i guess i was the the place where the
sort of mixing of that set of ideas from
from what's known in physics and ideas
that come from computation could sort of
get mixed and that's what made it
possible to have kind of the the step
forward that we've been able to have
with this sort of new approach to
fundamental physics
and that's fairly typical you know i
think had i even stayed sort of doing uh
physics as i did when i was a teenager
and a little bit beyond um you know i'm
quite certain that the physics project
we've now done would never have happened
um and or at least wouldn't have
happened under my
uh under my sort of uh leadership
and um
the uh it might not have happened for
another 50 or 100 years
um but it's um it's it's basically
because i've done lots of different
things which somehow one can use the
ideas from those other things on the
thing that one was on the original thing
rather than the sort of main line of
progressive innovation i mean typically
as i say when there are new
methodologies you've got five to five to
10 to 20 years when that new methodology
in some particular field is like really
hot you're figuring out lots of stuff
you know we've seen that with machine
learning for example in in the kind of
computational area you know a lot of
stuff gets worked out
in a period of five or ten years and
then it's a slower story after that
um and many are many many many other
examples that can be given of that
um and i think that's uh so
and then as i say it can be 50 or 100
years before you get the next shot in
that particular area
um
anyway i should i should probably wrap
up here in a moment but um
uh
yes i think i need to go but um parker
is commenting her on um
uh predicting the future and what the
future will be like um we'll talk about
that another time it's an interesting
thing i've i've had a you know a solid
50-year
span when i've been able to kind of make
predictions and see what happened with
them and i'd say one thing that's
interesting is there are inexorable
predictions about the future things
where i can just tell you this is what's
gonna happen it's like chug chug chug
chug chug you know that's how things are
going to evolve you can see the seeds of
something and you can see that over time
that thing will eventually become a big
thing uh even some things i've built
myself
i can see the inexorable future that you
know 50 years 100 years whatever those
seeds will have grown into big things um
you know it'd be nice if it happened
sooner but but uh you know might not
um where and then there are things where
it's a big surprise like just didn't
expect that
um and it's sort of an interesting
interplay between the things which are
the inexorable future and the things
which are the surprises of the future
and sort of recognizing where there
might be surprises is an interesting
interesting problem
i need to go and
look at some things actually that are
related a bit to building some of the
future of computation
um i think i should wrap up here and
thanks for a lot of interesting
questions and comments
and uh
i look forward to doing this again
hopefully next week